[Music]
professional snowboarder David Porter
is lucky to escape this raging avalanche
in Russia but his film crew catches
someone who didn't get out of the way of
the Avalanche a European hair this isn't
just a hair-raising experience this is a
hair racing experience like a bat out of
hell it powers its way through the
raging torrent of snow and defies the
odds making it to the other side it
escaped by a hair's breadth so forget
the chickens in the roads how does this
hair across the Avalanche the hair
doesn't sink into the snow because it
has a few adaptations to this kind of a
climate they have very large feet to
spread their low mass out over the
biggest area possible this reduces the
pressure they apply to the ground and
makes it less likely they're gonna sink
through the snow hairs can run extremely
fast up to 45 miles per hour or 70
kilometers per hour the great speed of
the hair is made possible by its hind
legs which have really long tendons
which store energy like Springs and
release it as the hair bounds across the
Avalanche it spends very little time on
any one bit of snow making it less
likely it's gonna sink in it's not
totally surprising that the crew didn't
notice the hair at first after all it's
evolved to be camouflaged against the
white snow to protect it for predators
the film crew actually got a picture of
the hair farther up the mountain so we
know it escaped unscathed a very happy
end to one very bad hair day